carrying on from
uh my last uh talking
i was thinking about uh
things that i've done and i could always
been the most demanding
but if i had to say
what got the most out of in feelings
internal feelings is tai chi
i found it much more readily available
the
the internal energy understanding
the delicacy of movement
the delicacy i suppose of non-movement
moving very slow
your your senses are more heightened
because
you are much more in than now as eckhart
tolle would say
his book the power of now
very good one to read if i'd recommend
it
he's made several but it's a very good
one to start with
to find the power of now
for most of us is impossible
but we won't keep still enough long
enough
or we'll think of anything to do rather
than
find that that now moment
the the yoga
and meditation
i found the most difficult
because yoga the teacher's always
telling you not to do anything
and yet they're asking to do everything
it's a um
a contradiction isn't it but they're
saying don't try
too hard and yet if you don't try you
won't get anywhere will you
i think it's like if you were on a
on an edge of a mountain
or plateau and you walk to the edge
and as you're getting close to the edge
you're knowing
that it's going to be
a big drop but you don't quite know how
far
you can see in the distance it's a long
way down
but when you get really close to the
edge that's the scary part
so with yoga it's like
get to the edge but don't get to the
scary part where it hurts the body
because then you're going to hurt
something you're going to damage
something pull
something strain something and
so many times have i thought that i was
going to the safe edge just to find the
next two or three days
that my body is telling me that i
actually
went over the edge and found that i was
hanging on
my fingertips on my toes
and i'd gone too far
so yoga and i still do yoga today and
i'm so thankful of it
but it's a very demanding
i'll say our hearts because i think it's
a body art
it really challenges the mind because
what you think you're doing and what
your
your ego your stubbornness ends up doing
is different the meditation
well to sit and to clear the mind
and not to think or hear counting
or have pictures come into your mind
just to sit there
why would you do that you might think to
yourself
many times i've thought of it why would
i
sit here and think of nothing
not talk to myself with the voice in my
head
why would i not do that when i've got
the opportunity
to talk think
why would i want complete blankness
complete
solitude from myself
from the world within what i live in
surely i shouldn't be wasting these
moments
every day you know give 30 minutes an
hour
watch meditation to lose that part of my
daily life oh no i couldn't do that
so until you overcome this and realize
that it's like we have all have to eat
food the quantities are different
but meditation is a food that will
enrich
the body but it's very difficult
like the yoga in a completely different
way you have
movement holding postures poses
very demanding well this is what i've
found
you may be thinking why is he saying all
that i don't find this problem
it's because we're all different and
this is the great thing
but tai chi oh it's wonderful you hold
the ball
you're feeling the energy between your
two hands
where is that energy coming from for the
first time you experience it
wow that's an electricity i didn't know
i could feel from holding the ball
we go to parting the horse's mane the
two hands drift apart
but it's like stretching that electric
that energy
from the ball and it's continuing you're
experiencing it
and yet part of your mind is telling you
the form itself you you learn
the form and now you're having to split
the mind
you're performing the thing that people
see and your experience the thing people
cannot see
perhaps they can by looking at
how serene you are and how beautiful
you're making the movements look
touches us internally
so we can see this with our eyes and
feel it with our
body i don't know if we have a soul or
not
but i use the word because it seems to
attach itself
to a good way of thinking about it so
when we say it touches our inner being
our inner soul
so why don't i stick to tai chi and not
aikido
well aikido
is a demanding challenge of perhaps
the things i've talked about this
morning
perhaps that is the ultimate challenge
not trying too hard and yet trying
being still when you want to be busy
or the world's busy around you
like you know his multiple attack
the world is multiple attacking you with
all its things being thrown at you
all the news all the problems in the
world all the suffering
all the joy
it's almost like you want to lock
yourself in a room
and sort it out before you leave that
room again
i hope you've enjoyed this talk please
subscribe to my channel
and comments are always welcome thank
you